[Música]
al menos 19 personas entre ellas nueve
menores perdieron la vida en medio de un
incendio registrado en el distrito de el
bronx en la ciudad de nueva york las
autoridades señalaron que hay más de 60
heridos y que se trata de una de las
peores conflagraciones en la historia de
la ciudad
avanza la jornada en el estado
venezolano de barinas tradicionalmente
chavista que repite las elecciones a
gobernador luego de pie del tribunal
supremo- cercano al oficialismo anulará
los resultados de los comicios de
noviembre en los que ganó el opositor
freddy super lar
el portavoz del gobierno francés gabriel
a tal salió en defensa del paseo vacunal
el funcionario resaltó que desde el
anuncio de la iniciativa ha aumentado la
demanda de vacunas entre los ciudadanos
galos las declaraciones se producen un
día después de las masivas
movilizaciones contra el proyecto de ley
que aún requiere la aprobación del
senado
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos esta emisión de noticias en la
ciudad de nueva york el alcalde erick
adams confirmó que 19 personas entre
ellas 9 niños perdieron la vida y más de
60 resultaron heridas tras un incendio
registrado en un complejo de
apartamentos en el distrito del bronx
que ya fue controlado los bomberos
aseguraron que el fuego inició en un
dúplex de los pisos 3 2 y 3 y la puerta
del inmueble quedó abierta por lo que el
humo se expandió a los demás niveles la
mayor parte de las muertes se produjeron
por paros cardiorrespiratorios por
inhalación de humo según las autoridades
se trata de una de las peores
conflagraciones en la historia moderna
de la ciudad
abriremos una de las escuelas e
inmediatamente accederemos a las
familias para que se les pueda notificar
a dónde fueron trasladados sus seres
queridos
y aquellos que vivían en este edificio
accedan a la escuela para que puedan
tener un lugar donde quedarse mientras
que la acción roja viene para poder
organizarnos y garantizar que reciban
los recursos
en venezuela avanza la repetición de la
jornada electoral de la que saldrá el
nuevo gobernador del estado de barinas
cuna del ex presidente hugo chávez a
luego de que el tribunal supremo
vinculado al oficialismo anulará los
resultados de noviembre en los que ganó
el candidato opositor freddy superlano
por un estrecho margen en la contienda
se enfrentan el ex canciller y ex yerno
de chávez jorge arreaza el representante
de la opositora mesa de la unidad
democrática sergio garrido y al
disidente de la oposición claudio fermín
durante 22 años barinas fue gobernado
por la familia de chávez hasta el año
pasado cuando su perla no logró una
ventaja del 0.3 por ciento frente al
hermano del ex presidente argentino con
lo que la contienda fue cancelada sin
resolverse escuchemos las palabras del
oficialista realza y el opositor garrido
aquí lo que nos interesa es que se
profundice la democracia y que voten
todos los barineses independientemente
de por quién vayan a votar y todas las
barinesas esa es la la incidencia más
importante que yo te puedo reportar es
que en tiempo récord a las 8 de la
mañana estaban instaladas todas las
mesas que están fluyendo bien la
participación buena marina
salió masivamente porque puede tener una
fe extendido en sus historia espíritu
santo y en este pueblo no le varía que
esta noche vamos a vivir la alegría más
grande que hayamos tenido
[Aplausos]
en brasil aumentó a díaz es la cifra de
fallecidos por el desprendimiento de
rocas de cañón en un lago de la ciudad
de capitolio minas de raíz el número de
víctimas subió luego de que los equipos
de rescate hallaran los cuerpos de los
desaparecidos que faltaban 32 personas
resultaron heridas en el accidente
entretanto se conocieron las imágenes en
las que uno de los niños rescatados se
reencuentra con su familia
en otras noticias miles de ciudadanos
protestaron en bélgica contra las
restricciones por el veloz avance de la
variante omicron del virus del cob y 19
en bruselas según los organizadores unos
25 mil personas inundaron las calles
para protestar en contra de la
vacunación obligatoria para rechazar el
pase sanitario y para denunciar la
autorización del de inocular a los niños
entre 5 y 11 años
el portavoz del gobierno francés gabriel
a tal defendió los beneficios del pase
vacunal que fue aprobado el pasado
jueves por la asamblea nacional el
proyecto de ley deberá recibir la luz
verde del senado en medio de la polémica
y las multitudinarias movilizaciones en
su contra rodrigo sedaron nos amplia
no cesa la polémica en francia en torno
al pase vacunal el pasado jueves la
asamblea nacional aprobó la proposición
de ley que sólo permitirá entrar a
espacios públicos a personas con la
pauta completa de vacunación ahora
deberá pasar al senado no exenta de
polémica entretanto este domingo el
portavoz del gobierno gabriela tal ha
defendido su implantación elegimos el
pase de salud y luego el pase de vacunas
y obtuvimos resultados después del
anuncio del pase de salud de este verano
12 millones de franceses fueron a
vacunarse después del anuncio del cambio
el pase de salud a un pase de vacunación
allí vimos una vez más un aumento de
personas que se vacunaron que recibieron
su refuerzo en el foro happel a tal
defendió esta medida ante la
obligatoriedad de la vacuna porque
afirma en países como austria no ha sido
efectiva sus declaraciones llegan
después de que miles de personas
salieran el sábado a las calles de parís
en protesta por la medida las marchas
fueron convocadas por el candidato de
extrema derecha florián filippo conocido
por su postura a favor de la salida de
francia de la unión europea
es un ataque a nuestras libertades no
estoy vacunado se lo digo inmediatamente
son nuestras libertades macro no respeta
la constitución por lo que es muy grave
para mí de papúa entre los manifestantes
aún resonaban las palabras de macrón a
le parisien el presidente dijo que tenía
ganas de fastidiar a los no vacunados
es sumamente grave que un presidente
diga eso la población lo odia
pese a sus declaraciones y una ola de
contagios que ronda los 300.000 casos
diarios en el país macrón sigue siendo
primero las encuestas están programadas
varias jornadas de conversaciones
diplomáticas entre rusia y occidente
esta semana la agenda la encabezan las
tensiones con quien rusia ha movilizado
decenas de miles de tropas a lo largo de
su frontera con ucrania y se teme que el
kremlin esté preparando una invasión
moscú busca un nuevo acuerdo de
seguridad de amplio alcance que incluya
una garantía de que no se permitirá a
ucrania ingresar a la otan
una dura advertencia ante las
conversaciones estratégicas entre eeuu y
rusia
la unión europea y los estados miembros
tienen una posición de fuerza muy común
los eeuu están juntos los aliados de la
otan están juntos y estamos diciendo muy
claramente y estas son palabras muy
claras que habrán consecuencias masivas
y un coste severo si rusia hacia
aventura en ucrania con una acción
militar una muestra de unidad por parte
de occidente en su intento de disuadir a
moscú de invadir ucrania
el kremlin centro decenas de miles de
tropas rusas a lo largo de la frontera
ucraniana un movimiento de vladimir
putin mientras aumenta la presión sobre
occidente para detener la expansión de
la otan al este
no puede aceptar que ucrania o georgia
se incorpore a la otan o puede que haya
llegado a un acuerdo con los estados
bálticos que son una causa perdida una
parte de la otan y todo eso
decidió aferrarse al final en ucrania y
la única manera de asegurar su autoridad
política sobre ucrania es creando
tensión en la frontera
el domingo en las conversaciones de
ginebra rusia dijo que no se dejara
amenazar para hacer concesiones se trata
de una respuesta a las posibles medidas
punitivas que discuten eeuu incluyendo
sanciones al círculo íntimo de putin la
cancelación del gasoducto ruso nord en 2
hacia alemania o la más drástica cortar
los vínculos de rusia con el sistema
bancario internacional la casa blanca
desestimó las exigencias del kremlin
sobre la otan como algo que no tiene
sentido tras el levantamiento ucraniano
de 2014 que derrocó un gobierno cercano
a moscú rusia ha intervenido
repetidamente en ucrania anexionándose
la península de crimea y apoyando los
levantamientos separatistas en dos
provincias del este
el ministerio de salud de kazajistán
indicó que 164 personas murieron en las
protestas de la última semana en rechazo
al aumento de los precios del
combustible
103 de las muertes ocurrieron en almaty
la ciudad más grande del país donde los
manifestantes tomaron e incendiaron
edificios gubernamentales con un saldo
de más de 2.000 heridos entretanto por
pedido de la presidencia la organización
del tratado de seguridad colectiva
alianza militar de seis estados ex
soviéticos liderada por rusia autorizó
el envío de 2.500 soldados en su mayoría
rusos a kazajistán como fuerzas de paz
para mantenerse en terreno hasta que la
situación se estabilice
finalizamos con información deportiva
porque comenzó la acción en la copa
africana de naciones
el anfitrión camerún venció por dos
goles a uno a burkina faso en el primer
partido del torneo los dos goles del
local los hizo desde el tiro penal
avanzan abu bakr la segunda hora de
etiopía perdió 1-0 frente a cabo verde
es todo por el momento en france 24
feliz tarde para todos
[Música]